the battle to influence the hearts and
minds of voters has begun and the UK's
political generals are readying their
digital armies not my words but those
who a message sent by momentum to
campaigners this week we need the
digital army to swing into action
straight away the Tories meanwhile were
urging their troops to beat labour on
digital but last night the rooms of this
game suddenly changed when the founder
of Twitter announced the political
advertising was to be banned on his
platform saying it brings significant
risks to politics where it can be used
to influence votes that affect the lives
of millions make no mistake this is
aimed squarely at this man Mark
Zuckerberg who owns Facebook and
Instagram
he believes well you can hear what he
believes for yourself political ads can
be an important part of voice you know
especially for local candidates and
up-and-coming challengers and advocacy
groups and the media might not otherwise
cover just that way they can get their
voice into the debate banning political
ads favors incumbents and whoever the
media chooses to cover Twitter's
decision probably won't make much
difference in the UK election Facebook
is the key battleground here come to our
analysis the party spent 1 million
pounds on ads like this in the last
three months alone but this argument
between billionaires tells us something
about this campaign the ground rules of
being set by tech companies and not by
government who haven't changed electoral
law for well over a decade rules are
written for a different age and it
shouldn't really be Silicon Valley
Chiefs are telling us what to do about
our election laws we should have the
kind of comprehensive fair and
transparent laws did we expect in every
other part of an election campaign
there's nothing special about social
media they should get them off the hook
throughout the election we'll be
covering this unregulated space with a
new project under the radar we've got
tools to monitor and investigate
activity online like spending on
Instagram of Facebook viral videos on
YouTube like this one from Nigel Faraj
influencing campaigns on Twitter and
we'll be looking at where the data comes
from those forms you fill in which are
then used to target you will also be
asking the big question what is
technology doing to democracy we'll try
and cut through the noise to give you
the clearest picture and who's behind it
on Sky News under the radar on all
platforms